ارصفه الطرق هنا في مدينه رفح تحولت الى
ماوا لمئات الاف النازحين الذين نزحوا قصر
من مختلف مناطق قطع غزه وضاقت بهم السبل
ولم يجدوا متسعا لهم في هذه المحافظه التي
باتت تمتلئ باكثر من مليون و200 الف نازح
والملاذ الوحيد لهؤلاء هو النزوح على هذه
الارصفه في ظل ظروف
صعبه نتابع واياكم هذه
المشاهد الحياه صعبه
نازحين وم قادرين والله تعبنا وحياه
المصحف ان تعبنا وحياه المصحف ان تعبنا
تعبانين وحياه المصب صبحت بن بنت اللي انا
قاعده
عندها وجهت من العيشه اللي انا قاعده فيها
افرج كيف وين بنشر بنشر في الخيمه وين
بطبخ بطبخ في الخيمه وين بشرب بشرب في
الخيمه وين منم منم الخيمه احنا والمصحف
تمنا وحياه المصحف بنت راحت استشهد داري
طاعت حينا راح
كل كل حياتنا تدمرت نزحت ثلاث مرات نزحنا
من التمين للمدارس
للبحر وانا ماشيه الد جلس ورانا
صبت وتم علاجي من مستشفى الميدان الامريكي
ولما خرجت خرجت بالخيمه ويتني قاعده
بالخيمه
وكاني قاعده في قبر تعبنا اقسم بالله تعبت
انا من خونس نقلوني عرفه والحين ما قدرناش
مالقيناش مكان نعيش حطونا في المدارس
طلعونا من المدارس بعد المدارس قعدنا في
خيمه الخيمه الله بيقول كده بيقول على
ثمان تنفار ثمان تنفار انا ولادي ثمان
تنفار احرام وفرشه ها الفرشه تعالوا
اتفرجوا تعال شوفوا الاحرام انا نفسه انا
نفسه ثان ايام والده وابني ما رضيتش اجيبه
عشان السقعه والثلج رميته في الحضانه وانا
ما بقدرش اجيب له بنبص ولا بقدر اجيب له
حليب من وين اجيب له حليب لا بناكل ولا
بنشرب عيشتنا شو شوفوا لنا حل احنا نايمين
على الب على الشوارع على الممار قاعدين في
الشوارع النهار كله من الصبح للمغرب هنا
في الشارع بعدين ناخد حالنا في الليل
للساعه 12 للساعه ده بنضل في الشوارع
وبنيجي بعدين بننام بنام اولادي انا فيش
وسع هيها فقالوا شوان بنام على الشقل كده
ودي تحت رجل مم طنبار تحت
رجليه قبور وزنازين اقل ما يصف الحال هنا
لعشرات الاف النازحين الذين تقطعت بهم
السبل فافترقوا الارض والتحف السماء هان
الشاعر لقناه الجزيره مدينه
رفح